tell me to start with cuomo right now so
you got you got a couple things that's
going on let's transition into that okay
so on one end you're seeing the story
about how you know
11 uh women are coming out okay well
first of all
do you know do you know who andrew cuomo
is yeah yeah yeah the governor of new
york
yes yes so you hear stories about his
stuff is coming out you know 11 not his
stuff is coming out but his stories are
coming out with 11.
his stuff's coming out yeah it's
definitely but 11 women are you know so
then the other day the awkward moment
where the transition from chris cuomo
to don lamont and don says brother
i love you you know chris today we're
going to talk about the governor of new
york
quickly kind of awkward but what should
happen to andrew should
biden's telling he should step down
should he step down dude he should step
down i just think it's amazing that
this is what people are grasping onto
rather than the fact that he put
basically human time bombs into nursing
homes
in new york bingo leading to thousands
upon thousands of unnecessary deaths
through his policies of putting
people who tested positive with kovit
back into nursing homes
somehow people like completely gloss
over this one and you know
out of the two out of the two sins
committed i think that uh that one is
the is the more serious one
yeah then you know it's not diminishing
you know how he's behaved towards women
et cetera i don't allegedly i don't know
all the details of that
but it amazes me that we're living in a
society where that one
is considered you know we can gloss over
that first thing and that's the one that
you know you think he should step down
absolutely he should have stepped down
i mean killed 50 000 people last year
when he was accepting well he got an
emmy award but we all know that's not
gonna happen so we all know that i don't
think he's going
to do it he wrote a best-selling book
what i'm saying to you is
all of that what you're saying that's
not going to happen he's not going to
step down because of
the nursing home that's not going to
happen i'm talking about should he step
down for these
allegations not allegations
investigation that comes up i'll just
read it to you biden calls como to quit
after damning sexual harassment report
the guardian reports joe biden has led
the calls from both parties for new york
governor andrew cuomo to resign
after an investigation new york turner
general later james unveiled the results
of investigation on tuesday shows that
como engage on unwanted groping kissing
and hugging
and made inappropriate comments to
multiple women i think he should resign
set the president
so it's not like uh you know you're
sitting canon asked about cuomo's
attempt to defend himself by using an
image in which he's
making physical contact with biden
himself the president said look i'm not
going to
fly spec this i'm sure there were some
impre embraces that were totally
innocent but apparently the attorney
general decided that there were things
going on so
he blamed his italian heritage i'm gonna
tell you we're a little handsome
come on man but but so on on this
on the premise on the story of eleven
should he resign based on that
i lean to a yes adam um
look there's a lot of people that are
asked to step down some people do
some people don't i mean
do i think he's gonna step down no i
also think you should do you think you
should okay so
they didn't what they're asking them to
step down for are these harassment
claims
hear you on that bro like the everything
you did with the nursing homes
i don't live in new york so i'm not
following all that much but
there is something called due process i
mean if these accusers
you know are not lying he does have
deserve his time in court i'm not a
cuomo guy or an anti-cuomo guy
you know i'm not i'm not should he
resign because of this because i don't
think he should resign i don't think he
will resign
but if the facts come out that he did do
this [ __ ] yeah
well the facts did come out there so
that's what they're saying not in a
court of law though
so if i if i'm in the president is
asking you to resign he's a democrat
it's not like a republican's calling out
a democrat
democratic political the president is
talking about a democrat calling a
democrat to resign
yes so this is this is exactly a lot of
a lot of the news
like trump asking desantis to resign and
would desantis resign
no trump if if trump asked to resign
if desantis had something like this the
amount of pressures would be for him to
have to resign well you brought that up
how many people when speaking of groping
asked trump to drop out of the race when
that billy bush
yeah you know i get what he say like you
said grab him in the position
they said him to drop out he wins the
race and he becomes the president i
think that i think
i think that's very different how is it
different i think that's very different
because
that would be like lit firstly that that
table is from like the 90s right
that was not in the 90s it was from wave
it was from decades before he became
decades maybe a few years billy bush
access
i think it was at least a decade before
i'm going to check it out but the point
is i think it is over 10 years yeah it
was a
it was that was a private conversation
right like let's be real we're all guys
here we're not let's not it was
locker room talk 2000
people we've all had conversations in
private that you wouldn't want someone
that you wouldn't want to come out
to show to the public right he wasn't
president at the time
it was a private conversation basically
every conversation i had with gerard
yeah yeah
exactly right you wouldn't want that
coming out there people make jokes
whatever
so you know and yeah so that's a
different thing to actually
like physically groping people and was
that done
while that's done while cuomo was
governor right yes am i correct
yes yes right so it's totally different
you're talking about physical
about here's the thing you're talking
about the fact that he was asked
i don't think i don't think cuomo should
resign because biden
said he should right i think what he
actually has done
if again allegedly if if he did it
and he's got that guilty conscience and
he's like you know what like
i screwed up then yeah i think by the
way is there a worse word
to your name than allegedly yeah
allegedly he donates all his money to
charity it never
it's always like allegedly he's doing
some grover here's a good word here's a
question
though go ahead well next five moves
right we're not asking the right
questions frankly why
you taught you said it's rare for a
democrat to tell another democrat
it is and it isn't because what is never
going to happen in new york
what will never happen in new york state
right now tell us
will a republican ever be elected either
mayor of new york city or governor of
new york state
i think so let's not say never i think
so juliana was there
not in this environment and not right
now we're talking 20 25 years old
i think the best ideas always wins so if
the people are sick of the wokeness
trust me
just trust me on this they would they
wouldn't they would not
the jersey just trust me they would not
be doing this
if they thought there was any any chance
of them losing
the the gubernatorial bid all right so
they're going to take out
cuomo who has tried to sprint left with
his rhetoric but is actually a pretty
moderate dude
yeah and why because they want to push
further left the the epicenter
of the far left progressive movement
justice democrats in particular
is brooklyn new york they have brooklyn
new york and they have la
and like like a cancerous cell they are
spreading from there
so right now you have yang and you have
aoc
aoc can moonwalk into the into the the
the mayor of new york she paul's
incredibly popular in new york
and yang is not polling well and they
want yang
yang with paul well as the governor so
the progressive wing of the party can
get a two for one
this is what i told you was gonna happen
the the democrats are not worried about
republicans because republicans
have no fight in them and they they've
given up on these areas they have no
fight whatsoever
they're not going after new york they're
solidifying the areas that they have
so now the democrats are cow towing to
the far left progressive wing of the
party
and the far left progressive wing in the
party is going after cuomo
so if cuomo is not going to resign what
cuomo needs to do
is push back and he needs to immediately
say hey joe biden that's an interesting
thing you think i should resign
what happened to that woman that you use
as a bowling ball that uh
that you ended up deciding you know that
that nobody needs to know about that
we're worried about trump
talking about grabbing a woman by the
kitty you were actually accused of doing
it
in the halls and she was your intern and
somehow someway
she disappeared on the campaign trail
somehow some way she went away why don't
you resign uncle joe
why don't you take uh corn pop and go
down to delaware and braid your leg hair
now i'm gonna stay right here all right
until you you resign
first and then i gotta define how
go down to delaware and braid your leg
hair then
corn
then you got cuomo needs to then
immediately turn
hard against the left side of the party
and that is how he can redefine himself
can we just we need to just defund all
of these politicians man
like slingshot i don't know again not
from new york
but who just allegedly won the allegedly
the mayor of new york city race it was a
black conservative
former who's winning mayor of new york
city that bill de blasio
but there's a new there's a new race
going on right yeah but it's not until
next year
is going out right there who's the guy
the top of the channel by the way let me
ask you he's a former police officer
far left if he resigns who takes over
if who resigns if governor if cuomo
rezans who takes over uh would be
his um uh the
assistant it's not the attorney general
they have a weird succession
they don't have an assistant can you
pull up who who takes over if cuomo
resigns kai just go google that real
quick who takes over
by the way is it ironic that the
governors of this would be his fourth
term by the way oh really they have no
st
is that ironic the governor of new york
and the governor
of california are both being asked to
respond they're getting recalled
who's kathy hokel kathy h-o-c-h-u-l
she's the next in line in case he was to
resign now i'll tell you somebody who
should have heard her name
kathy hokel see who that is chris
christie should have resigned after
bridgegate
and then that would have given him god a
fighting chance against phil murphy
right there
save the people of new jersey wikipedia
the these eight years of horror phil
murphy's
an american lord you're the ultimate
knucklehead
the bucktooth goldman sachs boston
first she'll be the first female
governor to new york states hogan
showed that the county clerk was around
2007 congress
she was assumed her seat in congress
previously she was a deputy county clerk
interesting so she would take over if
cuomo was to resign by the way andrew
cuomo's team
since you're watching this we have
reached out to you multiple times for an
interview request
multiple times if you could just respond
to us one time that would be fantastic
really appreciate you
and and what we reached out to them is a
special project that uh will be
announced here soon that
may may do pretty good uh i don't know
if you uh
we can reveal any of it but may do
something special here when it's uh
when it's launched anyways okay so cuomo
you're saying yes you're saying no
you're saying he's not going to
you're saying he should and you're
saying he should so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye